on poursuit donc sur le dossier de la
chine avec jones ou qui est professeur
de management à l'université laval jones
ou bonsoir bonsoir
qu'est ce que l'arrivée de joe biden
selon vous peut changer en termes de
relations commerciales avec la chine
vous parlez de relations commerciales
entre états unis et la chine n'est ce
pas d'abord hockey justement vous savez
monsieur peyton est à nos présidents
issus d'un nouveau parti il faut
attendre des ajustements l'endroit de la
chine
mais personnellement je pense qu'il faut
distinguer deux choses sur le fond il
faut le reconnaître il ya un consensus
de washington nouveau consensus va
chanter à l'endroit de chine
donc que ce soit démocrate ou
républicain était finie la chine comme
une sorte de compétiteurs stratégique
majeur ou bien quasiment une menace donc
sur le fond je pense pas que monsieur
peyton peut changer de façon importante
dans la politique que monsieur trois ans
pourra entamer alentours de chine par
contre au niveau dans la forme il faut
attendre beaucoup d'ajustements parce
que premièrement je pense que monsieur
pas et n aime pas trop de care tarifaire
donc ça rentre pas dans son principe
libéral moi je pense que il faut voir au
moin lé pari fou douanières qui était
une carte importante pour le
couronnement trempe deviendra beaucoup
moins importantes aussi bien sûr
monsieur payden pas essayer de
rassembler des pays afin de tourner des
pressions plus efficacement à l'endroit
de la chine cela il faut entendre çà
doit justement en fait c est ce qu est
ce qu il faut s'attendre à des
ajustements dans la politique touchant
huawei et les entreprises technologiques
et de télécommunications oui je pense
que vous savez gouvernement trois ans
plan de gouvernement d'europe
on parle beaucoup de ce fameux
découplage avec la chine et des
couplages avant tout c'est quoi un
économique et surtout technologique
personnellement je pense que vous savez
l'enjeu est très important pour les
américains pour la suprématie yannick
ton sévère qu'elle a percé ou le progrès
technologique de la chine inquiète
beaucoup les américains en tout cas à ce
sens là je crois que vis-à-vis de roye b
où les autres entreprises
créteil
chinoises prétendent à poursuivre cette
politique que sept ans la mesure
possible essayer de contenir sinon
freiner la perception ou la pub passé où
le progrès de compagnies chinoises donc
vis-à-vis de retrouver sa vie va rester
ainsi tueur mais il pourrait y avoir un
petit peu plus d action selon des règles
au lieu d'un seul ont justement tu à
certains de méthodes chaotique que le
gouvernement devra utiliser
oui mais moi je pense que la mesure va
demeurer avec toi oui ok et je vais un
peu vers le canada là est ce que joe
biden si la ligne est dure mais moins
dure quatre hommes sur huawei est ce
qu'il pourrait aller jusqu'à laisser
tomber la demande d'extradition de
maïwenn jo qui la numéro 2 de huawei qui
est toujours détenu au canada sa
séquence on espère parce que depuis
longtemps on a pensé que en fait la clé
et enlèvement des amis quart-temps
satoshi là parce que madame ans
son arrestation est étroitement lié
arrestation d'un autre micro même le
gouvernement chinois nier cela mais le
reste ce que vous savez à court même à
pratiquement moyen terme
je vois pas les impact si positif tant
c'est aussi la talent à part à mika
parce que vous savez monsieur peyton a
été élu dans un second temps une
circonstance difficile relate aussi d'un
coït économie problème racial excédera
doit être prioritaire et deuxièmement
c'est un dossier que le gouvernement
pourra tout fait pour que ce soit
quelque chose d'autre juillet tizi que
vous savez même le président a mis 15
ans tous les pouvoirs nécessaires pour
prendre divisions d'écart même quand il
s'agit est touchée comme cela c'est très
difficile de revenir ou moins dans son
premier temps de manta président quelles
sont les attentes de la chine face à la
venue du nouveau président des états
unis
moi je pense que vous savez si vous
regardez la situation de la chine
c'est que bon la chine a subi des
pressions extrêmes dans la part du
gouvernement de frappe
donc si monsieur trempe avait son
deuxième mandat
la chine va souffrir beaucoup c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je pense que ce
que entendre la chine
idéalement c'est quoi c'est qu'avant
dialogue parce que la chine est toujours
sur la défensive autant ce conflit avec
les amis cas quelle que soit président
mais avec pas éteindre la chine souhaite
que avait plus de dialogue afin d'avoir
une sorte une espèce de cohabitation
entre la chine et les autres pays qui
ont des systèmes différentes afin de
permettre la chine continue de ce
progrès il qualifie notre ascension
économique pacifique donc le petit
moment ils tant d'amis que demeure
toujours la priorité dans leur argentin
est le pire scénario que la chine
attendre pedn c'est au moins ça lui
permet de respirer à bhl parce que vous
savez la transition 38 ans 1 est autant
plus que la société la chine après les
élections présidentielles je suis pas
sûr que ça devient haddouchi si
important pour les américains
donc dans ce cas la chine va respirer un
peu ok alors on va respirer tout le
monde merci beaucoup de gens en dessous
très clair votre explication ce soir
merci au revoir